here's a fun exponent's question if 3 to  the x is equal to 5 to the Y is equal to  225 what is 1 over X Plus 1 over y equal  to X and Y are real numbers to work this  out consider each equation separately  take the natural log of both sides and  then bring the exponent to the front  solve the first equation for x and the  second for y then take the reciprocal of  each equation we now have a common  denominator of the natural log of 225 so  if we add the two equations we can sum  their numerators we have 1 over X plus  one over Y is equal to the natural log  of 3 plus the natural log of 5 all over  the natural log of 225. the numerator  becomes a natural log of 3 times 5 which  is equal to 15. 225 is equal to 15  squared we can bring the exponent to the  front and the natural log of 15 will  cancel out so we get the answer that 1  over X plus one over Y is equal to one  over two